que parece estar tan lejos.
Pero incluso en nuestro mundo desarrollado
vemos tensiones en las economías estancadas
y su impacto en la gente de nuestro alrededor.
Lo vemos en sectores enteros de la economía,
en los que sus gentes han perdido la esperanza en el futuro
y se desesperan por el presente.
Lo hemos visto en la votación del "Brexit".
Y con las campañas de Sanders y Trump en mi país.
Pero también en los países que empiezan a ser desarrollados.
En China, vemos como el presidente Xi tiene problemas
con el desempleo de muchos en la industria del carbón y la minería,
gente que se ve sin futuro.
Mientras que nosotros como sociedad vemos cómo resolver
los problemas del primer mundo y los problemas de los países en desarrollo,
tenemos que concentrarnos en mirar adelante,
y gestionar el impacto medioambiental de esas decisiones
Hemos estado trabajando en este problema desde Rio, hace 25 años,
el Protocolo de Kioto.
El Acuerdo de París es nuestra última iniciativa
y los consiguientes tratados sobre el clima
que están adoptando muchos países del mundo.
Creo que podemos tener esperanza en que estos acuerdos,
que son de abajo hacia arriba en los que los países han dicho lo qué pueden hacer,
son auténticos y efectivos para la mayoría de los implicados.
La parte desafortunada es que ahora cuando vemos un análisis independiente
de lo que estos tratados pueden conseguir,
la magnitud del problema se nos torna clara.
Esto es lo que la Administración de Información Energética de EE. UU.
ha evaluado qué sucedería si los países ponen en marcha
los compromisos climáticos acordados en París,
de hoy a 2040.
Aquí vemos las emisiones de CO2 en el mundo en los próximos 30 años.
Hay tres factores a los que prestar atención.
El primero es que las emisiones de CO2
seguirán creciendo en los próximos 30 años.
Para controlar el clima debemos reducir las emisiones de CO2 literalmente a cero,
ya que es el acumulado de emisiones lo que está calentando el planeta.
Esto muestra que estamos perdiendo la carrera de los combustibles fósiles.
El segundo factor a destacar
es que este incremento proviene de los países en desarrollo principalmente,
de China, de India y del resto del mundo
lo que incluye a Sudáfrica, Indonesia y Brasil.
conforme estos países están dando a su gente
comodidades mínimas de vida
que damos por hecho en el primer mundo.
A lo último que deben prestar atención es que cada año
expulsamos a la atmósfera 10 gigatones de carbono
que se dispersan entre océanos y tierra.
Sin contar los 550 gigatones que ya hemos expulsado a día de hoy.
Dentro de 30 años habremos expulsado 850 gigatones de carbono a la atmósfera.
Esto probablemente nos aboque
a un incremento de entre 2 y 4º C en las temperaturas globales,
acidificación de los océanos,
y un aumento de los niveles del mar.
Esto es un futuro creado por los hombres
y los actos de la sociedad,
que no debemos aceptar, sino cambiar.
Pero la magnitud del problema es algo que debemos entender.
Países diferentes toman decisiones diferentes.
En función de sus recursos naturales,
En función de su clima.
En función del camino seguido en su desarrollo como sociedad.
En función del lugar que ocupan en el planeta.
¿Están situados en zonas con poca luz solar o en latitudes medias?
Son innumerables los factores que determinan las decisiones de los países,
y cada uno toma unas decisiones diferentes.
El hecho abrumador que debemos tener en cuenta
es la decisión de China.
China ha decidido sustentarse en el carbón.
Los EE. UU. tienen una alternativa, pueden sustentarse en el gas natural.
Las invenciones del "fracking" y del gas de esquisto
son las alternativas que tenemos aquí.
La OCDE en Europa tiene opciones.
Las renovables que Alemania puede permitirse
porque es lo suficientemente rica para hacerlo
La energía nuclear en la que franceses y británicos están interesados.
Europa del Este, todavía muy ligada al gas natural y al carbón,
gas natural que viene de Rusia, con lo que ello implica.
China tiene muchas menos opciones y unas circunstancias mucho más difíciles.
Si nos preguntamos por qué el carbón es tan importante para China
tenemos que recordar la trayectoria del país.
China le dio personas a la electricidad
no electricidad a las personas.
No llevó electricidad a las zonas rurales,
sino que las urbanizó.
Urbanizó usando energía y mano de obra baratas
lo que creo la industria de exportación y un tremendo crecimiento.
Si nos fijamos en la trayectoria de China,
sabemos que la prosperidad ha aumentado drásticamente.
En 1980, un 80 % de la población China
vivía por debajo de la extrema pobreza,
por debajo de tener $1,90 por persona al día.
En el año 2000, solo un 20 % de la población china
vivía por debajo de la extrema pobreza.
Un logro notable a costa de algunas libertades ciudadanas
difícilmente aceptables en el mundo occidental.
Pero el impacto de toda esa riqueza
permitió a la gente tener masivamente una mejor nutrición.
Permitió construir tuberías.
Permitió construir alcantarillado.
Redujo drásticamente enfermedades diarreicas
a costa de cierta contaminación del aire externo.
Pero en 1980, y aún hoy,
el factor de muerte principal en China es contaminación del aire dentro de la casa
debido a que la gente no dispone
de combustibles limpios para cocinar y calentarse
De hecho, en 2040
se estima que 200 millones de personas en China
no tendrán combustibles limpios para cocinar.
Tienen un importante camino a seguir.
India también debe atender a las necesidades de su gente,
algo que va a hacer por medio del carbón.
Si nos fijamos en la previsión de la EIA en el uso de carbón en India,
vemos que producirá cuatro veces más energía del carbón que de las renovables.
No es porque desconozcan las alternativas,
es porque los países ricos pueden elegir lo que hacen,
y los países pobres hacen lo que deben.
¿Qué podemos hacer para reducir las emisiones de carbón a tiempo?
¿Qué podemos hacer para cambiar estas previsiones?
Porque con la voluntad necesaria sí podemos cambiar estas previsiones.
Primero debemos entender la magnitud de este problema.
Entre hoy y 2040
se construirán en todo el mundo entre 800 y 1600 nuevas plantas de carbón.
Esta semana, de una a tres plantas de carbón de 1 gigavatio (GW)
empiezan a operar alrededor del mundo.
Esto ocurrirá, aunque no sea lo que queremos
porque los gobernantes que velan por sus ciudadanos
han decidido que es lo más beneficioso para ellos.
Y es lo que va a suceder a menos que tengan una alternativa mejor.
Y una de cada cien de estas plantas
gastará entre el 1 % y el 3 % del presupuesto mundial sobre el clima.
Así que cada día que piensen en hacer algo contra el calentamiento global
recuerden que en algún lugar se ha abierto una planta de carbón
que operará durante 50 años,
y acabará con nuestro poder para cambiarlo.
Hemos olvidado algo que Vinod Khosla solía decir
sobre un capitalista americano de etnia india.
A principios del 2000 nos contaba
que para que China e India abandonasen los combustibles fósiles
había que crear una tecnología que superase el test de "Chindia".
"Chindia" es la combinación de las dos palabras.
En primer lugar, tendría que ser viable,
un plan que técnicamente pudiesen implementar en su país.
Y que fuese aceptado por la ciudadanía de sus países.
Segundo, debería ser una tecnología expansible,
que pudiera aportar los mismos beneficios
y con la misma rapidez que los combustibles fósiles,
para disfrutar del estilo de vida que nosotros damos por hecho.
Y tercero, debería ser costo eficiente
sin ayudas o mandatos de pago.
Tiene que ser sostenible por sí misma,
no ser mantenida para tanta gente.
Si algunos de estos países tienen que rogar
o si algún otro país dice: «No comerciaré con Uds.»,
todo para conseguirla, ese cambio no se dará.
Si miramos el test de "Chindia",
vemos que no tenemos ninguna alternativa que lo cumpla.
Eso es lo que nos dicen las previsiones de la EIA.
China está construyendo 800 GW en plantas de carbón,
400 GW de hidráulicas,
unos 200 GW de nucleares,
y con respecto a la energía, ajustándose a la intermitencia
con unos 100 GW de renovables.
En plantas de carbón 800 GW.
Están haciéndolo, sabiendo el coste mejor que ningún otro país,
y conociendo la necesidad mejor que ningún otro país.
Pero eso es a lo se dirigen en 2040
si no les damos una mejor opción.
Para darles una mejor opción hay que cumplir el test de "Chindia".
Si nos fijamos en las alternativas que tenemos,
existen dos cercanas a cumplir el test.
Primero, la nueva nuclear de la que enseguida hablaremos.
Una nueva generación de plantas actualmente en proceso de desarrollo
alrededor del mundo
y quienes las están diseñando dicen:
«Podemos tener las demostraciones en 2025,
y a nivel global en 2030, si nos dan la oportunidad».
La segunda alternativa que podría funcionar a tiempo
es la solar a gran escala apoyada por el gas natural,
que podríamos usar hoy mismo versus las baterías que están aún en desarrollo.
¿Qué está frenando la nueva energía nuclear?
Regulaciones desfasadas y un pensamiento anticuado.
No hemos puesto en práctica nuestro conocimiento en salud radiológica
para aplicarlo a cómo nos comunicamos con el público
y controlar las pruebas de nuevos reactores nucleares.
Debemos utilizar los nuevos avances científicos
para mejorar las regulaciones que tenemos en la industria nuclear.
El segundo asunto es
que pensamos que se necesitan 25 años y entre 2000 y 5000 millones USD
para crear una planta nuclear.
Esto se lo debemos a la visión militarista
del origen de la energía nuclear.
Estos investigadores
dicen poder generar energía a cinco centavos el kWh.
Pueden generar energía por cien GW al año.
Pueden demostrarlo para 2025,
e implementarlo globalmente para 2030.
Si les damos la oportunidad.
Actualmente estamos esperando un milagro.
Pero lo que necesitamos es una opción.
Solo se implementaría si es segura y barata.
Lo que quiero que hagan no es tan solo llevarse esta idea,
sino escribir a sus gobernantes,
escribir a los directores de las ONG que apoyan,
y pedirles que les den a Uds. la opción,
no el pasado.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)